hello lead I'm a trader I wonder the
world buying and selling wares
especially to find folk like your good
self some little girl I saw said you of
a sister and her birthday and it seemed
you haven't got her a present yet it
just so happens that I have a war of a
nice box of sweets here guaranteed to
put a smile on any sister's face for
only free gold pieces hello little
brother I hope you haven't forgotten
what day it is like you did last year
I'm sorry if I woke you up last night
it was another of those dreams I was
standing in this field when something
happened but I can't remember what never
mind that though I'm still waiting for
my present
I have a new student for you put it in
the dorm upstairs with the girl you
don't look much like hero material to me
but Mays knows what he's doing I suppose
well follow me then
you'll be sharing this room with whisper
one of our brightest young pupils she's
playing in the woods right now but
you'll meet her in the morning
well now you should get some sleep your
training starts tomorrow
let's continue our training with the bow
to begin with see if you can hit the
three stationary targets and put some
effort into it
the longer you pull back your bowstring
the more damage you will cause but make
sure you stay within the circle not well
the dumb Coulomb hole
again
Reznik
let the apprentices approach for many
years now you have worked hard to earn
yourselves the title of hero today that
apprenticeship ends and you go out into
the world to do great deeds deeds that
will bring you the gratitude of Paulo or
strike fear into their hearts these are
dark times the shadows of Albion are
stirring and strange winds are blowing
your choices whether they lead you down
the path of good or evil will change the
face of the world
now take your viewed seals and vente for
as
you